salomé 21 ans a été battu à mort par son
concubin à cagnes-sur-mer 100e
féminicide depuis le début de l'année en
france chaque année environ deux cents
dix neuf mille femmes adultes sont
victimes de violences conjugales
physiques et ou sexuelles 121 une femme
sont mortes en 2010 805 femmes sont
mortes depuis le début de l'année
emmanuel macron a déclaré que la grande
cause de son quinquennat serait
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
madame la ministre l'égalité c'est la
mort les effets d'annoncé n'ont jamais
protégé personnes le grenelle des
violences conjugales ne protégera pas la
femme qui prendra des coûts de ce soir
et qui peut être mourra de véritables
peine à perpétuité doit être prononcée
en cas de féminicide et non pas des
peines à perpétuité qui dure 20 ans
madame la ministre ce drame des
féminicides appelle une réponse urgente
stop à l'immobilisme stop au blabla
seriez vous prête oui ou non à voter la
proposition de loi de mon collègue
aurélien pradié qui pourrait apporter
dès le mois d'octobre
de véritables réponses concrètes et
urgentes
dans le secteur de l'énergie la france
dispose d'un formidable champion avec
edf numéro deux mondial de la production
d'électricité grâce à edf entreprises
voulu par le général de gaulle soutenu
par tous les gouvernements successifs
depuis réformer en 2004 la france
réalise un triple miracle à la sur son
indépendance énergétique elle est le
pays d'europe qui le bilan carbone par
habitant le plus favorable et elle
fournit aux français et à nos
entreprises
une énergie à très bas prix par rapport
à nos voisins européens
étrangement votre gouvernement qui
depuis deux ans ne cesse de nous vendre
dans tous les domaines industriels des
projets de fusions acquisitions a cette
fois décidé un plan de scission de
découpe de l'entreprise avec d'un côté
edf bleus qui regrouperait le nucléaire
et l'hydraulique et de l'autre des f
vert avec les activités de services de
distribution et le reste des énergies
renouvelables
cette scission soulève donc de
nombreuses questions pourquoi casser ce
qui marche alors que nous en avons tant
besoin pour la transition énergétique
quel sera l'avenir de la filière
nucléaire dont ceux dans ce schéma quel
prix de l'énergie pour les français dans
un système qui ne sera plus intégré bref
monsieur le ministre
en quoi ce projet certes il les intérêts
de la france et des français et pas
seulement les intérêts privés de ceux
qui conçoivent et organise ces scissions
[Musique]